this video is brought to you by keeps
what's up guys Michael here and like
many of my Millennial kin I've always
looked at sitcoms from How I Met Your
Mother In The Mindy Project to Scrubs
and even It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia for insight into what to
expect from my 30s
[Laughter]
you know the close-knit group of friends
The Local Tavern where everyone knows my
name the will they won't they sexual
tension between me and at least two of
the five people that I see daily and
while I'm definitely this close to
getting the Barista at my local
Starbucks to stop writing Michelle on my
cup it's hard to shake the feeling that
life is a little lonelier for me and my
generation than our TV friends before us
and it's not just me no matter what my
mom says political scientist Robert D
Putnam explored this issue in his 1995
book bowling alone which shaped the
current discourse on loneliness and
social isolation Putnam observed that
from 1980 to 1993 more people were going
bowling on their own than ever before
this led to his theory that Society was
collapsing because Americans weren't
participating in groups and clubs like
they used to thus undermining
communities of trust and cooperation
Putnam in a classic dad move partially
blamed television for the spike in
loneliness because it privatizes our
leisure time but TV was just the tip of
the Lonely Iceberg as according to a
2003 UCLA study the internet quickly
became the go-to space for lonely young
people often to their own detriment so
is the internet the reason we're not
bowling like Lebowski or on a first name
basis with our neighborhood bartender
let's find out in this wisecrack Edition
did the internet make us lonely okay but
before we get into it I want to tell you
about this week's sponsor keeps keeps
makes it easier and more affordable for
guys to prevent hair loss and since two
out of three guys will experience some
type of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35 Keeps Us relevant to a
lot of people but with their
subscription service you can fight back
against hair loss and hang on to the
hair you have the process begins with a
free consultation with a licensed keeps
Doctor Who can help decide which
combination of over-the-counter
medications and FDA approved
prescriptions are right for you these
hair loss prevention meds will arrive at
your home every three months so you
won't have to set an annoying reminder
to remember to go to the pharmacy for
your refill as your treatment plan
continues you can message your keeps to
actor 24 7 to update them on your
progress and ask any questions you might
have but here's one answer to one
question you might have while individual
results May Vary it typically takes
between four and six months to start
seeing results so if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com slash wisecrack or click the
link in the description to receive fifty
percent off your first order that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash wisecrack now back
to the show long before any of us had to
explain the difference between our real
friends and our internet friends to our
parents and also long before my wife had
to ask me if I was inviting any of my
internet friends to our wedding
philosophers were arguing that humans
are fundamentally communal beings or as
Aristotle put it man is by nature a
social animal he believed this so
fervently that he argued Community is
integral to human survival in his book
an inquiry concerning human
understanding Scottish philosopher David
Hume concurred writing indulge your
passion for science but let your science
be human and such as may have a direct
reference to action and Society be a
philosopher but amidst all your
philosophy be still a man the gist being
that if we delve too deeply into
individual or intellectual Pursuits
we're missing out on a fundamentally
social aspect of what it means to be
human and as we've mentioned before
according to Hegel we only develop our
individual self-consciousness through
being recognized by another
self-consciousness and as such human
subjectivity is absolutely dependent on
society and relationships with others in
general most philosophical accounts of
human consciousness acknowledge that
Consciousness is not something we can
really do alone however as any introvert
will tell you being alone and loneliness
are not necessarily the same thing the
concept of loneliness is more
complicated than simply being home alone
on a Friday night the word wasn't used
to describe an emotional state until the
romantic era before that loneliness was
used to describe a physical state of
being like the lonely thin men I leave
in the sleeve so I can say well at least
I didn't eat the whole box I just left
one
so I guess I'm good anyway most people
chilled in communal librarian societies
and those who didn't like priests and
monks lived alone to commune with higher
Powers they weren't described as lonely
so much as solitary because their
isolation was a choice things began to
change with the Advent of the Industrial
Revolution people began to move from
their family farms and agrarian
communities into cities and while this
offered new opportunities for
socializing and Pub crawls it also
created the conditions for new types of
isolation and you guessed it loneliness
many had to move away from their
families for the first time and even
those who did live with their families
would be spending long hours in
factories only coming home in time to
have washed the soot off their faces and
sleep for a couple hours before going
back into work and that's not even
getting into the full scope of the
physical and psychological exploitation
of workers taking place during this era
which which would be a whole other video
or series of videos and they'd all be a
bummer not coincidentally around the
1830s loneliness and individualism both
appeared as words in their conventional
meanings for the first time this rise of
individualism severed people from their
concept of community giving birth to our
modern understanding of loneliness and
once conceived it would quickly become a
mainstream experience by the mid 20th
century philosopher Hana or rent argued
that loneliness once a borderline
experience usually suffered in certain
marginal social conditions like old age
has become an everyday experience of the
ever-growing masses of our century and
explaining the rise of totalitarianism
in the early 20th century she argued
that loneliness at the scene for people
to accept oppressive governments
explaining that through the use of
isolation and Terror totalitarian
regimes created the conditions for
loneliness and then appealed the
people's loneliness with ideological
propaganda now if you want to help us
fight against totalitarianism you should
check out our new stream wisecrack live
it happens every Thursday at 11 A.M
Pacific right here and you know it's a
way to fight loneliness make new
internet friends and really make sure
that we don't all collapse into a
totalitarian society that is the stuff
of nightmares today loneliness is no
longer simply the state of being
physically alone it's grown to Encompass
a complex cluster of emotions ranging
from Melancholy and regret to envy and
desire and don't forget the fear of
missing out or as it says on this
prompter and I don't want to say this
word but I will
fomo experts have even labeled
loneliness and epidemic because it has
been linked to high blood pressure heart
disease obesity a weakened immune system
anxiety depression cognitive decline
Alzheimer's disease and even death with
each generation seeming to become more
lonely than the last people have started
to point fingers at the internet and
social media is this a classic case of
technophobia or is the internet actually
making us worse social media apps have
long identified themselves as spaces for
community and connection with slogans
like Instagrams capture and share the
world's moments or twitters here your
voice matters come as you are and
together we'll do what's right not
what's easy to serve the public
conversation or metas meta metamates me
but according to multiple studies users
who engage with social media apps most
frequently report greater feelings of
loneliness than those who don't it's
almost as if these apps aren't actually
aimed at creating Community but instead
function as digital marketplaces more
concerned with profit than their users
feelings but social media didn't invent
commodified loneliness even if it may
have perfected it according to British
Economist norina Hertz we can for the
500th time turn our eyes to the election
of President Ronald Reagan for context
Reagan came into Power after a 20-year
long period of economic stagnation he
adopted the ideas of Charles Murray a
social darwinist who argued against the
social safety net he wrote when the
government intervenes to health it not
only diminishes our responsibility for
the desired outcome it enables the
institutions through which people live
satisfying lives basically his logic
went helping people who were struggling
made them lazy and engendered more are
struggling so I guess that's why at the
end of Titanic Kate Winslet lets
Leonardo DiCaprio swim on his own and
then die he added that social safety
nets even cause existential malaise
writing give people plenty and security
and they will fall into spiritual
torpert to which I say try me this all
marked the emergence of neoliberalism or
a type of societal and political
organization that prioritizes free
markets limited government as well as
individual choice and responsibility
according to Hertz neoliberalism is one
of the chief culprits of the loneliness
Scourge we face today she argues that
this emphasis on the individual didn't
just change our society's approach to
money and the social safety net but also
our relationships with each other along
the way sources of social support
ranging from college loans to
government-sponsored Health Care became
competitive and the public was
emotionally severed from the idea of
collaboration and community in his
failed 1976 campaign Reagan stoked
racial resentment by popularizing the
idea of The Welfare Queen I.E mothers
living in poverty who supposedly had as
many children as possible to get more
government benefits by the way since
then um that whole theory has been
completely debunked so hey there you go
it wasn't a real thing once in office he
capitalized on these divisive
mythologies he dismantled the New Deal
and Lyndon Johnson's Great Society
cutting 22 billion dollars from social
welfare programs in 1981 and 1982 alone
Reagan's policies also directly
undermined and eventually collapsed
labor unions which have been vital in
creating solidarity amongst workers in
addition to providing communal spaces
like union halls which often had bars So
Reagan was attacking all of us that like
to I don't know hang out at a bar after
work and let off some steam The
Disappearance of the social safety net
pushed Elders the unhoused and
immigrants to the margins Community
deprived people turned to consumerism
for happiness as writer George monbio
explains in the context of neoliberal
loneliness consumerism fills the social
void but far from curing the disease of
isolation it intensifies social
comparisons to the point at which having
consumed all else we start to Prey Upon
ourselves in this way mon bio notes that
neoliberalism redefines citizens as
consumers whose Democratic choices are
best exercised by buying and selling
rather than by say I don't know
agitating for social change and Hertz
argues that loneliness is a personal
societal economic and political problem
comprised not only of feeling bereft of
love company or intimacy but also
feeling unsupported and uncared for by
our fellow citizens our employers our
community our government but the
internet was meant to be a solution to
these growing feelings of isolation at
least that was the goal of Tim berner's
lead the man credited with inventing the
World Wide Web he originally created it
as a place where scientists could share
data then open the source code up to the
public with the dream creating an opened
and Democratic platform the idea was
that the World Wide Web could transcend
political parties governments and even
the individuals self to bring people
together to create an ideal society that
was decentralized a qualitarian
harmonious and free obviously he thought
all this before the Matrix came out all
of a sudden there were group chats email
discussion lists multi-user dungeons
bulletin board systems and live Journal
all created with the goal of human
connection nothing could stop this
digital utopianism but then corporate
interest started to seep into the
internet as they saw an untapped Market
to be mined for profit initially
advertisers were worried about the
internet because it potentially could
allow individuals to avoid the
advertising that dominated other mediums
but that wasn't gonna fly while the
internet had been incubated under U.S
government control in the 70s and 80s
specifically by a military research
organization and notably paid for by
Public Funding that would start to
change in 1985 it expanded to allow the
National Science Foundation to oversee
aspects of the internet to be controlled
by research universities by 1989 the NSF
decided to make the internet a
competitive market and started letting
industry take over the hardware and
infrastructure eventually in the free
market happy 1990s the federal
government would seed control over the
Internet entirely in hopes the
competition would increase the spread of
the web a lot of this had to do with
silicon Valley's place in the cultural
imagination as writer Adrian Chen notes
the near Universal celebration of
Silicon Valley as an avatar of free
market capitalism in the 1980s helped
ensure that the market would guide the
internet's developments in the 1990s as
it became The Cutting Edge technology
that promised to change everything long
story short the web a place that
promised a space of digital Community to
counteract the 80s drive for
accumulation was itself commercialized
meanwhile Venture capitalists threw down
cash to build the first generation of
surveillance advertising companies
public policy fell by the wayside
because the government took a
laissez-faire approach to regulating the
internet their attitude let the market
sort out the morals and ethics of
surveillance advertising because the
market is good at morals and ethics cut
to today and data collection from social
media companies like Facebook have been
used to support advertising that
influence the 2016 election and
regularly targets teens when they're
depressed because that's when they're
more likely to buy stuff so they can
tell when teens are depressed and they
don't then send them Mental Health
Resources they send them to amazon.com
because there's a sale basically this is
why the creation and fostering of
community ceased to be a priority for
the early internet as profit took over
as the driving motive for users it's
never been more obvious the social media
apps are driven by competition not
connection just look at the early
ranking system of Myspace friends to the
obsession with follower accounts and
likes on Instagram Twitter and Tick Tock
and for all my gen Z friends out there
Myspace was a website where you you had
a picture and then you ranked your
friends and everyone put a song on their
page you'd go to their page and
immediately you'd hear a really bad like
early 2000s emo song it sucked but if
you saw the Myspace page uh put a link
in the comments let's all check it out
and comment on them social media apps
like Instagram are a marketplace where
you're pushed to advertise yourself to
be more brand than human arguably this
Fosters isolation more than it does
community and if you happen to catch our
video about Tick Tock you know that
lonely and depressed people are more
likely to spend time on social media
apps which is particularly concerning
considering loneliness is contagious
it's no wonder that according to a study
in the American Journal of preventative
medicine young adults who use social
media the most frequently were three
times more likely to feel lonely than
those who used it the least in short
trying to cure loneliness with the
Internet is like trying to get hydrated
off an espresso Martini it's like fun
for 30 minutes and then it feels really
bad in this way the internet is kind of
like the Fool's Gold of community we
post about our lives and enjoy the
dopamine Rush of 10 000 likes worth of
validation but the interaction itself
doesn't have any depth we sacrifice
authentic connection for the scale of
the response this is the problem at the
center of many internet communities
they're organized around shared
interests but relationships rarely
Foster meaningful personal connection
that's because there's no Mutual
accountability between ourselves and
others on the internet which is why you
can make fun of me in the comments with
no fear that I'll show up to your
parents house with printouts of all your
[ __ ] posting so they don't get your
Christmas presents this year the
atomization of the internet has also had
a huge impact on our physical world it's
given us the ability to be complete
Hermits we can work from home order
doordash and have unlimited
entertainment within the confines of our
living rooms Studies have also found
High rates of screen time impact kids
and teens abilities to recognize
non-verbal emotional cues
did you get that if not you might suffer
so not only does the internet make us
lonelier but it also makes us worse at
communicating we called out to number
one and now you're just going for me
next
you're just trying to get everyone out
no it's not a domino effect it's a Pizza
Hut effect
so is the internet evil in and of itself
of course not however it is a reflection
of our world meaning that it also
perpetuates values like individualism
and competition that directly undermine
feelings of community collaboration and
belonging so when it comes to loneliness
is there really no Escape
maybe maybe not but there are pockets of
the internet which still carry some of
the communal Spirit of the early days
for one online gaming communities are
actually well communal according to a
2007 study from Nottingham Trent
University which looked at 912 players
of massive multiplayer online
role-playing games from 45 countries
these games are extremely socially
interactive in fact 10 of the gamers in
the study even ended up in romantic
relationships with other Gamers and
mental health professionals have even
begun to find Direct psychological and
social benefits from gaming what's more
the internet has long been a place where
marginalized groups have been able to
find Community one study found that 96
of young queer people say the internet
has helped them better understand their
sexual orientation and or gender
identity and internet OG Tim berners-lee
is currently working to decentralize the
internet altogether with a small team of
developers Tim has created solid a
platform designed to give individuals
rather than corporations control of
their own data berners-lee said the Long
View is a thriving decentralized
Marketplace fueled by personal
empowerment and collaboration that is to
say his original vision of the internet
this could potentially lead to less
power on the side of shady social
networks and hopefully more room for
wholesome internet communities but it's
still in development and if we've
learned anything it's that genuinely
non-commercial digital spaces you
usually have about three and a half
weeks before the data hungry vultures of
digital capitalism get a hold of them
and turn them into another source of
Revenue but hey we'll always have those
three and a half weeks
I guess but what do you think are we
stuck being individualist consumers
above all else can the internet make us
less lonely or will it continue to
exacerbate our isolation please let us
know what you think in the comments a
big thanks to all our patrons uh please
check out our patreon page if you
haven't in a while we're doing a lot of
fun stuff there like this video to make
us feel validated by you our internet
friends and as always thanks so much for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign